[Music]
today we're gonna be talking about those
alleged cyberpunk multiplayer leaks
as well as changes that we want to see
come to the single player in those big
huge patches that we're expecting
i'm lucy and joining me today is jake
decker hello
and john luxeitke hi hello lads
let's talk a little bit about these
cyberpunk multiplayer leagues
uh very top level it originally came
from dso gaming
but they found in the game's executable
files
some references to the multiplayer modes
so what they've been able to gather so
far is that allegedly there will be a
standard deathmatch mode
as well as heists um we will link our
story and the original reporting below
if you want to dig in deep into it but
let's start by talking about what our
hopes are for cyberpunk multiplayer jake
i'll come to you first what do you want
to see from it
i want to see co-op stuff and it sounds
like the heist might be that i'm not
super interested in the multiplayer pvp
partly because the game
like i i don't know playing the game i
it doesn't feel as good as
most first-person shooters that have a
competitive side to them
that being said like maybe on pc it'll
be better they'll do some refinements
and whatnot
but i'd be super curious to see what
they could do with some
co-op especially with cd projekt red
storytelling uh like it would be cool to
have something similar to
divinity maybe like smaller scale
divinity missions where you
and your crew that specked into
different abilities can
head into a heist maybe and maybe one
character is really good at talking to
people and you can talk your way into
a secured area and then another person
can be your sharp shooter or something
like that
like i don't know i'd be curious to see
how those different gameplay styles can
kind of complement each other and make a
fun co-op experience and funny you said
that about having roles because
it looks like um what they've managed to
find are references to different
character classes i guess we all
expected that we wouldn't be able to
take our v
into multiplayer um however they have
been finding
references to different classes they
seem to be called
first of all i love the fact that the
files are called uh muppet
uh so there's a solo assassin netrunner
and techie um which i'm pretty
interested in
i think netrunner obviously in assassin
and techy are pretty self-explanatory
solo i wonder if that's going to be more
of your kind of
soldier class your kind of brute force
john what do you reckon
yeah that's the part that i'm the most
curious about is how they
change the classes because uh if there's
one thing i would like them to do is
maybe
make those classes feel more distinct um
like in the in the single-player game
you know
like as a netrunner if you want to like
role-play a netrunner you could do
hacking but you still
kind of have to combine that with like a
fusion of of guns or stealth so i
i would like to see um if they are
adding new abilities
into the multiplayer especially because
there are some abilities that you
probably
can't make work in a multiplayer
environment like being able to slow down
um or like really being able to like uh
like
how do how does like hacking and enemies
optics work in multiplayer actually that
sounds really cool i would like to see
that we're like you just lose
the ability to see for like 10 seconds
um
but but yeah because the way the game is
designed you can kind of
spec in any the game is pretty flexible
so i
i guess it would be a lot more rigid so
like i assume an assassin you would
really
want to stealth you probably have a
katana
because that's usually what you do when
you're an assassin in a video game
um techie's the one like i'm not really
sure entirely what the difference
between a techie and a netrunner
would be so i'm i'm curious
what the distinction between those two
are yeah i think that's especially
interesting because
technical ability is kind of what you
see in the game
and technical ability has to do with
crafting and opening certain doors and
whatnot so i don't know how you would
spin that out
into a full character class so i'd hope
that the techie in particular does get
some
offensive abilities that would make
playing that more interesting because i
think even now playing the techie as
v it can be kind of dull and give them a
turret
maybe yeah give them a turret they can
throw down i was going to say it feels
to me
and i'm maybe this is just because in my
head i'm thinking of what traditionally
single player games have managed to have
a successful multiplayer component
and you've got to think of like mass
effect 3 some people might not call it
successful but i think that's like three
multiplayer that's great
i think everyone likes that game's
multiplayer i i don't think people liked
the way that the um
it had to feed in to get like the best
best egg
okay um but also like ghost of sushima
as well so these are the games that i
kind of have in my head but
referring to mass effect 3 obviously you
had the engineer class which is maybe a
little bit more of where i see techie
going which is more um
tech armor maybe help beef up your squad
a little bit and improve people's armor
but as well putting down turrets would
be really cool
cdpr have previously said that
multiplayer would be
its own standalone thing so i'm very
interested in seeing how we're gonna
like all group up online if there's
gonna be any aspect of a social space
um jake what do you reckon yeah that's
something i'm also super interested in
because
i think that especially as of late when
people aren't able to socialize as much
i think social spaces can be very
important in games like this
so i'd be curious to see what that kind
of looks like like are you gonna have
you're gonna have apartments that you
can invite friends over to and then you
can plan a heist kind of like gta style
or maybe can you like go to a bar and
there'll be other players there and you
can pick up missions
and group up with them from that aspect
it's kind of hard to say um but i hope
if they do add a social space
or or if they add like mini games or
something to pass the time because that
is kind of an odd thing that was left
out of cyberpunk entirely but it'd be
nice to like
i don't know hang out at a bar drink and
play games with your pals
that's what i was gonna say is um
like the direct comparison is gta online
and i think that's a fine route to go
with the game but like yeah gta has
built in like you know all these
elements like they
they added recently in gta online like a
casino like this that you can go to and
there's all these like you know casino
uh mini games and elements you can do
that cyberpunk just doesn't really have
so i think they would need to
add a lot more of that to the game um
because i don't think just like
deathmatch would like really hang
in the long term like you you kind of
need to create a a space that
has more variety in what you're doing um
so people feel like
more invested in like hanging out there
in the long term or like role playing
with their friends
a game that does that really well is red
dead online so obviously being a prequel
um yeah the prequel story it's like
in red dead online for red dead 2 in
particular
you get to go and take missions from
bonnie mcfarlane
and sadie adler and other characters
that you encounter both in red dead 1
and red dead 2 which i think is a very
smart way
of attaching you further to a game even
though it is a standalone
kind of property so i would and
we know that it's probably not going to
be a v johnny silverhand story but i
would love to
you know go to the afterlife and talk to
rogue if this was had some kind of like
prequel element
some story through line to keep me
invested
how about jackie yes
i would absolutely love that definitely
really wanted to see more of jackie
judy yes i would love that
okay so those are our hopes and dreams
for cyberpunk multiplayer we will of
course be keeping you updated as we hear
more
uh but it sounds like we're not gonna
get multiplayer for at least a year i
think cdpr have said it's gonna be 2022
which
feels like a lifetime away however there
are gonna be big changes coming
to cyberpunk's single-player campaign
obviously there are going to be some big
huge
patches coming and boy do we have a list
of things that we want to
see fixed in the game beyond bugs
because otherwise we would be here all
day and they have been releasing these
hot fixes to address a lot of the bugs
however there are just some things at
the kind of core gameplay level
we don't want to be backseat game
designers but these are some quality of
life improvements
that i think we would all love to see
john luke you've made
a list i've
uh yeah just like like you said i i'm
not trying to be a backseat game
designer but there's like certain things
that the game does
that i think they could just like easily
fix or hopefully easily fix
uh that are like nice quality of life
changes so i'll just run through these
real quick
and you guys can let me know what you
think of them uh first off
uh the crouch button and the skip dialog
button are the same
button and so if you are stealthed and
you start a conversation
you have to remain stealth the entire
time you can get around that
and i found out by accident oh really
you hold
the crouch button i tried that i just
kept skipping dialogue and i was like
i'm not gonna touch it
it doesn't always work sometimes it does
but
just clear up that distinction that'd be
great yes uh and then moving on to
another example where
buttons serve the same purposes uh when
you're like using your scanner ability
to like try and like ping enemies um
and you want to like zoom in because
you're trying to like scout a base it's
the same
like button to like pick your hacking
stuff so if you're on a person you can't
zoom into them you have to like i i have
this trick where i have to like look at
the sky
zoom in a bunch and then turn
find a way to i don't know i'm not sure
i i get that like they ran out of space
on the controller
but it's like i'm just like it's
maddening to me i'm like oh my gosh
uh please fix that uh other stuff
small things uh don't let people call
you in the middle of dialogue
that's happened to me several times
where i have a conversation just like
cut short also on top of that i
think they need to uh adjust the length
of time
when uh before a player uh an npc
responds to you
so so when you when you're picking your
dialogue option if you wait like
two seconds they'll be like oh hey v
you're still here
are you still here you're listening to
me you listen to me and i'm like yeah
i'm trying to make an important decision
about what i want to say
leave me alone they want you to know
that they recorded all that dialogue so
they got to use it they got to make it
known give me just
increased increase the length of time
like maybe 10 seconds like
it's it's so short and it just like it
stresses me out
like someone who's like i i just want to
take the time to make this decision
um and then the other one is
uh please chill on all the notifications
about people trying to sell me their
cars
i think it's cool you can buy cars in
the game i love the amount of options
i'm constantly getting that ping i'm
just like it's it's
my phone is blowing up about cars and i
do not care
like 90 of the time they need it i just
i don't know like there needs to be
another a better way to do that that
isn't so like intrusive
so i was thinking about that and i would
love
i agree i think the pings are egregious
and they happen
way too frequently i would love it if
they just emailed it to you
and if you want to go track them all
down you basically have
a version of autotrader that v can
access
when they hack or when that whenever
they use laptops or terminals not
terminals but whenever they use laptops
they can just go on it's like this night
city auto trader
and everything is there and maybe you
just get emails from them so you can
read through and then they appear on
your quest log
rather than hey i got this cool car
can't afford like just popping up every
five minutes
that and um i would love if they changed
the icon
on the map because i'm like going
through the map and i'm trying to figure
out like what side quests i haven't done
and it's like oh nope that's a car
that's a car it does say when you hover
over it at least it does say
i know what you're saying it'd be nice
to separate that so i can like look at
the map and be like yep i've done all
the side quests
as opposed to it looks like there's
still a ton of side quests but they're
all
quarter of a million dollar cars that
players yeah just change it to a little
like
a car icon would be cool um
another one would be uh let me ping
items for junk for quick selling
um would be great you there there is a
junk system
but it's just like there it's just
specific items that are junk and i would
love if i could just like go through my
weapons and like ping like ping for junk
and then i could just sell them all in
one go that would be a nice
i thought that i don't think
i ever ate or did anything with and it
was just i was just hanging on to it
um so that would be good i'd like that a
big one that i know a lot of people
talk about is uh letting me access
re-access the character creator or
change your hairstyle mid-game
i think it's a huge one that uh i
imagine they'll do just because so many
people have like requested that i would
love for them to
because it's like it's cyberpunk i
should be able to just like walk into a
place and be like
i want to change my face you know like i
i think they
they probably have to limit it where i
don't think you should be able to
necessarily maybe change like your voice
or
your your gender once you pick it in
just because of like
story purposes um but being able to
adjust the face and hair
just go to a ripper doc like add that
section into a ripper dot cost a flat
amount of money and then you just get
the character crater again you could
change it what was it saints row 2 had
the plastic surgeon you could go to
where you could
change your character that was always a
nice touch exactly
uh and then on to on top of that i would
love to see them add
more character customization options
specifically colors
i thought the colors in the game were
pretty limited um
there was no like true black
in the colors it was always like a
greenish black and i was like add a true
black
would be great um and then my final one
which actually will lead nicely into
jake's was
uh let me look at the clothing um
on my character before i buy it it's
like super annoying so like
you just have to look at the little tiny
icon and you don't know
how it's actually going to look on the
if you're specifically buying for
fashion versus buying for just armor but
that kind of leads into the larger issue
about
the whole armor fashion system which i
know jake you
you have thoughts on yeah so
unfortunately i know a lot of people
have talked about this too
but the game is super interested in
fashion
and what v wears but unfortunately it's
all tied to armor stats so you need
to be wearing like if you're like me you
always want the best equipment but
unfortunately the best equipment usually
looks stupid
so i'm running around looking like a
looking like an idiot
but i'm apparently pretty badass cause
i've got a
nano armor fiber coat or whatever but
that kind of also brings up a bigger
point that i wanted to make like it
would be kind of cool if there was a
hardcore version or i don't want to use
hardcore but if there was like
another way to play the game that kind
of did away with a lot of the arbitrary
rpg stuff this is probably pretty
controversial because i know
i love rpgs too but it would be kind of
nice to
you know like not be picking up weapons
constantly that
are the same model but slightly better
it would be cool if it was more focused
around the crafting which is an
entirely underu underutilized element in
the game
like i'd rather just have one gun that i
maybe saved up for and purchased and
then
from there i can upgrade it maybe take
it to
uh one of the shopkeepers who or one of
the gunsmiths who can
upgrade it and whatnot as opposed to
just flipping through weapons constantly
because
i find a gun i like i don't use it that
long though because i find something
that's better and if i want to deal with
these higher level enemies i kind of
need to switch to it
and then also just goes for like the
food you're talking about lucy it'd be
nice if
you know you know there was a there's a
hunger system or something like that and
i know
i know we're kind of leaning into into
backseat game development here which i
don't want to get too far into
but but that was always one of my
favorite aspects of a lot of similar
rpgs like
fallout new vegas for example had a
really great hardcore mode
that that made all of these useless
items
useful like water and and food as
opposed to just like
giving you like a little extra hp or
stamina boost or whatever
like you had to kind of maintain that
and i know that's not for everyone but
it would really make me feel more a part
of the world
and then also you can't just like go to
a bar and have a drink
i mean you can you can buy a drink but
then you just go to a menu and do it
even though in the game there's a bunch
of drinking animations that you can do
in cut scenes so be cool to kind of
separate those
out so if you want to just hang out in a
bar and just chat with the bartender or
whatever you could do that and
sip on a beer or something i would
personally love
a very small quality of life update but
i find driving
i i actually kind of enjoy driving in
cyberpunk however i think
having the player icon in the center of
the map when you're driving at speed
is a real issue and i have overshot
things so many times just because
i don't know that there's a bend coming
up uh and i just have to do a really
awkward u-turn in the middle of the
highway
so i would love to see that just
adjusted just a little bit
um so i think fair to say a big list of
things that we would love to see
personally improved in cyberpunk 2077 in
those big new patches that
are gonna be coming up if you have your
own suggestions please
leave them in the comments below we
might do a follow-up video
and for all things cyberpunk we've got
so much we've got so many guides
let's plays the whole kitten caboodle
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to gamespot and we'll see you
next time
you